this has been the lineage from the left
it's been conservative Christian
conservative Republican Party all right
white nationalist white supremists Nazi
this lineage and they are all one in the
same they've used this alt-right
umbrella term so that's not lost on me
and it's become obnoxious that's why
people don't believe these stories when
they happen they don't believe it again
like you say you have to do your
research because he cannot hold on a
second is this a real story because I've
been called a Nazi and then by those
same people I've then been called a
filthy Jew sure so it's hard to look
yeah I'm neither by the way not Jewish I
don't mean I'm not a filthy Jew thinking
about this story if it feels as though
this is this is a you know retread
territory if it feels well you've been
here before you go let's go to these
white nationalists white supremists it
seems familiar it's because we have been
they are much more similar to an tyfa
than they want to acknowledge and i know
i'm gonna get so much flak for this in
the either downvoted i get it ant if i
saying don't compare us to that fascist
scum and then the white nationalists say
you you're you're missing it you open
borders cuck neither of which are true
but an tyfa and white nationalists are
far more similar than i think they have
more in common than they have apart and
and the rest of america is unfortunately
caught in the crossfire by the way
before i do this let's make sure that
both groups are completely disassociated
from from a conservatives and then
separate from conservatives even impress
even president donald trump racism is
evil and those who cause violence in its
name are criminals and thugs including
the KKK neo-nazis white supremacist and
other hate groups that are repugnant to
everything we hold dear as Americans we
are a nation founded on the truth that
all of us are created equal we are equal
in the eyes of our Creator we are equal
under the law and we are equal under our
Constitution and I think that was
fantastic that was very well said
because that brings us to our first
point where antifa
and white nationalists
our most alike and by the way I know
white nationalists some all right people
that I'm making some generalizations
here I get that there are factions on
both so we are going to have to use a
general rule number one they have no
regard for the law or the Constitution
they're both right they don't believe in
peaceful assembly if you look at it it's
it's been mob rule and this isn't just a
one-time thing it's a pattern
they're both violent you look at the
anti-trump protests where there have
been trash cans lit on fire people have
been assaulted repeatedly you look at
the Steve caliz Scalise shooting which
was a Bernie supporting anti-fur
supporter and of course I think there
was the the Baton Rouge that was black
lives matter and they kind of wanted the
same so I'll give you that one but the
latest violent in Charlottesville on the
white nationalist front okay so clearly
they're not really believing in rule of
law they understand the idea of peaceful
assembly well
here's maybe why they have no respect
for the Constitution that Donald Trump
just pointed out anti food doesn't
believe in the First Amendment they
actively fight out against the First
Amendment when it's anything they don't
like like you see in Berkeley they
accuse everyone of being Nazis and now
you have actual potential Nazis and no
one wants to listen anymore because your
little boy who cried Nazi so they don't
believe in the First Amendment whereas
white nationalists when we address the
Constitution don't believe that all
people were created equal if you look at
the Declaration of Independence that's
right in there they don't believe that
they all agree on one thing
equality is a dangerous myth the
alt-right is united in rejecting the
current dogma that all races are equal
and I know people say he's all right
that's a species of white nationalist so
no respect for the founding documents
the constitutional rule of law they both
have that in common now that's not what
conservatives believe that's not a
conservative idea so that brings us to
number two both of these groups promote
identity politics and both of them play
the victim card to get their way people
are gonna get so mad about this I can
see the white nationalist not liking us
how dare you well anti-fur they do it
through the things that we know right
privilege checking they believed that we
needed we need segregated safe spaces
they believe that we need to have forced
social reengineering we need people need
to be have mandatory sensitivity
programs and schools right they want to
prepare the systemic racism which has
oppressed insert minority here it's the
victim card all day long
well white nationalists promote identity
politics for reasons that are obvious
and they claim that they're being
persecuted they claimed
they're the victim of white genocide
both of them use this victim card both
of them now not to let's not even
necessarily get into the validity of
those claims just talking about the
techniques that they use to try to get
their way that's how they set the
premise in order to try and use what
brings us to point number three they
both support and request big government
liberal policies that's it we're victims
therefore we need let's look on the ant
if aside the victims need what
reparations they need big government
they need taxes they need subsidies they
need affirmative action they need
welfare policies they need bailouts
because this is the ruling class we need
we need big um to step in and help the
lower classes you know the bottom ninety
nine percent ninety percent eighty nine
percent eighty percent sixty percent who
ever make less who ever makes less than
you how do the white nationalist solve
their problems through big government
economic protectionism again social
reengineering class organization and as
we're all aware the far-left anti-fur
they want single-payer health care well
okay yeah but so do white nationalists
in the all right babe repose
nationalized health care now the only
difference is that anta they claim that
it can be done by what vilifying anyone
wealthier than them white nationalist
claim they can do the nationalized
health care plan by vilifying anyone
less white than them so they both want
the same goal they just said one says we
can do it if we take if we steal more
crap and then these folks say we can do
it if we infringe on more people's
rights who don't look like us so these
are the top three points where they they
have a lot in common but there's a bonus
round here
of course they both hate jews so when i
say that i mean they both want israel
wiped off the face of the map and i
don't mean that just in a kind of sort
of so let's get past the war of sixty
seven both the far left and the white
nationalists a lot of the alt-right that
extreme wing of it have sided with
palestine in the current conflict i
think this is important you've talked
about this a lot Gerald here's where we
are now let's let's get past the history
and their van acts of brutality on both
sides and obviously this has just been a
quagmire okay let's give you that but
right now today Palestine is run by
Hamas in Hamas is current charter they
include the eradication of the Jews
by the way not just Israel the Jews mind
you so I don't know how they plan to do
that in Queens but they're there inching
their way forward like someone saying to
me he wears a little R if today the
United States said Canada has no right
to exist so this is really all it is if
you are on the side of Palestine at this
point you don't believe that Israel has
a right to exist that's all I believe
they have a right to exist period Hamas
says they don't have a right to exist
for you to side with any of these
governments lining up with Hamas against
Israel you don't even have to like Jews
you can find them annoying you don't
have to like their food you just have to
agree that they have the right to exist
as human beings okay so to give you an
example let's say right now the United
States Donald Trump said Canada has no
right to exist our goal is to eradicate
the Canadians and I said hold on a
second I I think that's wrong
I actually I side with Canada on this
one then someone says who are you are
you pro Trudeau no I'm not I just think
the Canadians have a right to not be
suicide bombed that's what we're talking
about you don't have to like the Jewish
people you just have to believe that
they have the right to not be killed for
being Jewish so the top way is that the
alt-right the anti feh and the white
nationalist side of alright it's
important by the way to note that this
is not necessarily all of the alt-right
especially when the left wants to throw
everything want you to think of yours
truly is all right sometimes Ben Shapiro
and Jordan Pederson and Dave Dave gay
former Young Turks Rubin so you let them
know if there are any other comparisons
that you think are valid or ones that
you would like to see comment send your
tweets to us and we'll be sure to pay
close attention to every single one hey
you like this video subscribe by
clicking the button that says subscribe
if not there's a strong chance that
you're an Armenian genocide denier wink
wink
I think you know what I'm talking about
but I don't over there this isn't the
channel for you I'm sure you'll find
something there that you deem very
insightful and informative also I
request that you come back here
afterward and immediately leave a
negative comment because we read those
and those affect our lives directly we
care about them because we care about
you